[Music]
y'all it is stunningly beautiful out in
DC today we're about in the mid 50s and
uh I have a couple things I need to get
done this afternoon so I thought I'd
bring you with me and tell you a little
story about my favorite set of poi right
now and why they're my favorites drexier
from drexfacture POI sharing with you
the love of poi spinning and flow Arts
to benefit your body and brain and today
I'm going to share with you my secret
weapon but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and and
special thanks to the non-business
Friends of the channel Lei machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission so we're just going to start
things off with spoilers here these are
my favorite set of poi right now they
are fabric boy sock POI that come from
the sockboy store that is run by Katya
stakonova she of one day spin Fame and
it's kind of strange that these would be
my favorites right now because quite
frankly I've never had a strong
proclivity towards sock point in the
past and when I first got them there
were some things that I really liked and
some things that I wasn't super
impressed with so how do they become my
favorites I've always thought that they
look pretty you know I remember when the
first footage of people in Russia
spinning with them started becoming real
popular on Instagram and YouTube I
definitely was like super duper excited
to try and get my hands on a set and
when Katya sakanova offered to send me a
set for me to review I was all about
that life and then I got them and you
know they while they look beautiful I I
also had some mixed feelings you know
for one thing they were a little bit
longer than I would have liked I
definitely have a favorite length for
POI right now that hovers right around
the 23 inches Mark and they were
definitely longer than that adding to
that was the fact that you know all of a
sudden I found that all of these
techniques that I was used to using for
stalls and plane breaks you know I it
just didn't look as clean with the sock
POI couldn't really do contact play with
them and it made Gunslingers really
really challenging so while I did have
them I didn't actually use them that
frequently for the first few months that
I had them so then what changed so one
of the biggest things was that I
realized that a lot of the things that I
thought were bugs were actually features
for one thing the fact that I had a
really rough time with stahls and plane
breaking with them originally I thought
that that was just because it doesn't
look good with sockboy but what I
realized over time is that what's
actually going on there is that my
technique just wasn't super clean I can
fake a lot of technique with contact POI
because it focuses the attention
just on the relationship
between the head and the handle so if
I'm going to do my stalls and I'm going
to do my plane breaks you know if the
tether isn't perfectly straight out it's
pretty hard for people to tell whereas
when I do these things with sock POI
well it just forces me to be a lot
cleaner in my technique you know if I'm
going to do stalls and I'm going to do
plane breaks then it means that I have
to pay attention not just to the
orientation of the heads and the handles
but also to what the tether's doing
because with sock POI the tether becomes
really really obvious the next point is
honestly just one of convenience it has
to be said sock POI perhaps more than
any other set of poi I've ever had
travel really really well they're really
Compact and Squishy and unlike contact
POI they don't by default take up a
bunch of room I have a little bag that I
like taking with me from place to place
and quite frankly using sock boy is just
really convenience I find that I have
enough room not only to stick in the
sock boy but also to stick in a notebook
my iPad and a couple other things too if
I want to whereas if I would try and do
this with contact boy it would pretty
much just be the contact point in the
iPad it also has to be said sock POI are
a really really good fit for dance as
they get drawn more and more into dance
as an aspect of my POI style I find
myself being more and more drawn to such
a POI that visually complements the
dance that I'm working with and sock boy
are fantastic at this not only do they
make things like pendulums and body
tracers look really really cool but well
they just kind of have a visual Flair to
them that makes the dance really stand
out in a way that I appreciate it also
has to be said they're a great fit for
shooting educational videos because they
take up so much visual space they show
up on camera incredibly easily and even
better than that they make for great
thumbnails they're very very easy to
separate out from the rest of the video
footage plus which the Vivid colors just
make the POI pop in footage overall
whether it's instructional footage or
flow footage they just pop so much in
the video that it's really really easy
to tell what the intended POI trick is
and what I happen to be doing with them
it's really really a good fit for video
and honestly too sometimes when I spin
contact POI I get a little too focused
on trying to get the tricks down when it
comes to my dance the sock boy really
make me focus on the dance itself and
what I'm doing with the POI instead of
trying to do tricks there's something to
be said for a set of that limit your
truck set a little bit that really
forces you to make the tricks that you
are working on even cleaner and really
driving home what you're trying to
accomplish with them so yeah I have to
say I'm a fan they have become the
default POI that I take with me
everywhere now and I don't think that's
going to change anytime soon so I think
it's kind of awesome that they've grown
on me over time I don't currently have
an affiliate deal with sockpoy but I'm
still going to recommend them anyhow you
can grab a set for yourself by heading
over to
sockpoy.store you can grab a set for
yourself tell Katya that I sent you and
she makes amazing sets of poi and
hopefully you'll get as much joy out of
them as I do
foreign
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel grow and of course this video
would not be possible we're not for the
kind support of all these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
would like to become a supporter and
you're not currently one you can go
ahead and do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you all right I have made it
to the metro station so it is now
officially time for me to mask up so I
can head down to the museum thanks so
much for joining me on this walk if
you'd like to check out some flow arts
equipment reviews that I've done I will
leave a link to a playlist of them down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you're watching on YouTube uh
please make sure to get outside and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
very soon
peace